this is a Fox News Alert we have just
learned moments ago that a U.S
contractor was killed and five American
Service members injured after their base
was struck by an Iranian drone in Syria
now in response the Pentagon conducted
what they call Precision airstrikes in
eastern Syria against the groups they
say are affiliated with Iran's Islamic
revolutionary guard we'll bring you more
details as we have them
but this does raise more questions as to
whether we should have Americans there
in the first place hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else